repasamos la prensa internacional con
rosa pérez más de euros a bienvenida
feliz el lunes festivo aquí en colombia
nosotros comenzamos vamos a hablar de
los 10 años del fin de eta empezamos con
el país luego tenemos el diario punto s
en españa' rosa buenos días raúl exacto
pues en motivo de estos 10 años que se
cumplen desde que ésta cesó su actividad
está hermana armada pues distintos
medios de comunicación española están
haciendo pues especiales y
particularmente hoy porque en donostia
una ciudad del país vasco también
conocida como san sebastián en español
pues ha tenido lugar un acto esta mañana
hora europea en que los principales
dirigentes de la izquierda
independentista vasca de la izquierda
'abertzale' pues han leído una
declaración de la llamada declaración
del 18 de octubre si te parece vamos a
los titulares raúl así es empezamos con
el país como lo adelantábamos otegi a
las víctimas en el décimo aniversario el
fin de eta' sentimos mucho dolor eso
nunca debió ocurrir así titula el país
exacto porque lo que destaca este
artículo es que otegi no este histórico
al líder de la izquierda independentista
del país vasco pues por primera vez en
esta declaración ha pedido perdón
particularmente a las víctimas de eta no
como señala el país no ha sido una
perdón exactamente con estas palabras
pero sí que ha expresado su pesar y como
dice el titular sentimos mucho su dolor
y dijo esto nunca debería haber ocurrido
y por qué es tan reseñable el hecho de
que pidieran perdón particularmente a
las víctimas de eta que concretamente
fueron
853 en términos de asesinatos pues
porque hasta ahora siempre la izquierda
independentista
enmarcaba dentro de las víctimas del
conflicto a las víctimas de eta dentro
de las que también pues se con tan se
cuentan las víctimas del llamado
terrorismo de estado' o violencia
policial así es rosa vamos con el mismo
tema con el diario punto es la izquierda
'abertzale' rompe con eta y se disculpa
de corazón nunca debió haberse producido
así titula el diario exacto pues es que
como comentamos esta es la noticia del
día
este paso más allá que da la izquierda
'abertzale' ahora pues se constituirá
dentro de lo que es la representación
parlamentaria dentro de bildu lo que
representa a otegi y por otro lado
dentro de sortu que es el principal
partido dentro de esta coalición y pues
el diario punto es destaca los
principales cinco puntos de esta
declaración del 18 de octubre que por un
lado pues recuerda esto el compromiso de
la izquierda independentista vasca con
pues está dejar las armas de un lado por
otro lado destaca no había trampas no
sino una real convicción de dejar la
violencia de lado por otro lado esto no
tan señalado que la paz duradera sólo se
puede conseguir con el reconocimiento de
todas las víctimas por otro lado piden
también que se termine definitivamente
con la política penitenciaria de
dispersión de los presos y pues por
último dicen hay una asignatura
pendiente a la raíz de este conflicto
que es el reconocimiento del país vasco
de euskal herria como nación
así es rosa vamos ahora con otra noticia
en europa las pre presidenciales de
francia famoso con lemon editorial no
fragmentos de francia en la antesala a
las presidenciales como van los
franceses rosa exacto lo el mont lo que
ha querido hacer pues de cara a esta
campaña electoral francesa que sin duda
aquí vamos a seguir muy de cerca ha
querido llevar asciendan de sus
periodistas a movilizarlos por lo que es
todo el territorio francés acompañados
de fotoperiodistas precisamente haciendo
una crítica no a este pues periodismo de
expertos que nos salen digamos a la
calle y que comentan desde un plato ha
querido pues encontrarse con los
franceses a cara cara y endo pues a
escuelas peluquerías etcétera y estos
reportajes se van a publicar a lo largo
de los próximos días y semanas pero en
esta editorial de hoy el periódico
avanza tres conclusiones de de todos los
testigos no que han podido recoger sus
periodistas por un lado destaca no es
cierto este escenario de guerra civil
que se plantea precisamente desde muchos
platós televisivos que dan voz a estos
dice comentadores en ciertos discursos
del odio y ciertos discursos racistas
dicen no es así realmente la sociedad
francesa por otro lado sigue con la
resistencia de la sociedad francesa
durante la pandemia y termina con la
disociación entre lo que es el debate
mediático y el debate real y las
preocupaciones de los franceses semana
que titulamos chile dos años tras el
estallido social vamos a un página 12
municipios retira mobiliario de plazas e
instan a comercios a cerrar temprano
este lunes exacto porque hoy se cumplen
dos años de este estallido social que
llevó hasta la reforma de la
constitución que está en manos ahora
mismo de la asamblea constituyente
chilena y precisamente este aniversario
llega en un momento muy caldeado en la
política y en la sociedad chilena
recordemos la implicación de sebastián
piñera en los papeles de pandora y en la
proximidad de las elecciones
presidenciales chilenas que se van a
celebrar a finales de noviembre y
básicamente este periódico destaca la lo
que es la preparación a nivel de
seguridad
después el centro de la capital y de
otras ciudades del país y cerramos con
una nota un poco de color con el
fotógrafo spencer tunick famoso por sus
fotos al desnudo vamos con the gardian
se siente muy natural cientos posan
desnudos para la sesión de spencer
tunick cerca del mar negro
exacto raúl pues esta es esta sesión que
perdona que ha habido un error en los
titulares pues es al lado del mar muerto
pues ha tenido como intención
y reivindicar la necesaria lucha contra
el cambio climático y por eso pues este
fotógrafo tan conocido por sus fotos en
las que retrata a cientos y miles de
personas desnudas ha querido pues
señalar cómo retrocede este mar que
según las informaciones que nos da este
artículo lo hace un metro cada año rosa
pues gracias por todo ese panorama
internacional en revista de prensa nos
vemos mañana con más información ahora
vamos con nuestro primer invitado el día
[Música]